das hier ist für mich der Star des
türkischen Frühstücks wir machen
menemen und dafür brauchen wir folgende
Zutaten Olivenöl Chili pumin
Spitzpaprika Tomate Knoblauch Zwiebel
Eier Petersil und wenn man möchte ein
bisschen feterkäse zum toppen beginnen
wir indem wir ein wenig Olivenöl in die
Pfanne geben dann geen wir die Paprika
in die Pfanne zuerst die Paprika weil
die braucht am längsten wenn das ganze
ein bisschen weich ist kommt eine
gehackte Zwiebel dazu einfach mit
anschwitzen und dann leicht Zeit
versetzt der Knoblauch wenn Knoblauch
und Zwiebeln glasig sind gebe ich
Tomaten dazu normalerweise benutzt man
frische aber die schmecken im Winter
danch nichts deshalb habe ich gche aus
der Dose genommen jetzt geben wir etwas
Chili dran ganz wichtig Kumin also
Kreuzkümmel außerdem ordentlich Salz und
später können wir noch ein bisschen
Pfeffer rangeben wenn das ganze
eingedickt ist können wir einmal
abschmecken sehr lecker also geben wir
jetzt unsere Eier dazu einfach oben
drauf schütten und dann direkt anfangen
die Eier zu verrühren und die werden
jetzt parallel quasi in unserer
Tomatensoße stocken jetzt toppe ich das
ganze noch mit ein bisschen feterkäse
und fertig sind unsere menem dazu noch
ein bisschen Fladenbrot und der Morgen
ist perfekt denn